sa séquence et jordan cheyenne une maman
youtube deux américaines l'aide diffusé
par erreur à ces cinq cent mille abonnés
les soeurs déjà pendant une minute la
trentenaire demande à son fils de 9 ans
de pleurer devant l'objectif alors
qu'ils viennent d'apprendre que leur
chien malade et pour obtenir la prudence
qui illustrera la vidéo elle n'hésite
pas lui montrer comment faire
non mesdames autorités montrent leurs
traditions tollé sur les réseaux sociaux
et les excuses de jordan n'auront pas
suffi elle a désactivé sachets nuit
elle était contrainte de fermer sa
chaîne oui heureusement heureusement
parce que c'est complètement pathétique
fin ce genre de manipulation des enfants
hommage pour ça mais les grotesques
salaires quel est le but en fait quel
est le sujet c'est juste pour se faire
des abonnés peut-être un peu d'argent je
passerai là je la connais pas mais ce
qu'elle fait des placements de produits
ou des unboxing mais c'est d'une
violence
dans dix ans je sais même pas où il va
se construire mais avec une mi temps 10
ans alors pas les images mais
c'est pas moi c'est fiona qui a beaucoup
de talent
[Applaudissements]
excuse moi ce film et c'est la réalité
de l'influencé alors là peut-être que
c'est poussé à l'extrême avec les liens
avec les enfants mais pardon il n'y a
que des mises en scène pour faire une
photo pour faire un placement de produit
pour faire une vidéo c'est normal en
fait c'est juste la réalité on montre la
réalité
même temps le maillot on est là c'est
qu'on met en scène des enfants se sont
désabonnés jour na'vi l'allemand sensui
mais c'est un biais d'une agence
bancaire nabila le bon ces enfants et
s'ils ne sont pas tous elle le met
censure et rendez vous de lui avec des
petits look moi pourquoi pas mais c'est
ma classe et une mise en scène qui
vont ils connaissent pas les tenants et
les aboutissants de youtube de l'
influence il ya énormément d'argent qui
est fait derrière cette femme elle est
suivie par six cent mille personnes ou
trouve ça très moyen pour les enfants il
ya des lettres connues dans son école
de faire la même chose mais c'est juste
la réalité faut en prendre conscience
des jolis en numéro 1 au numéro 4 on à
la famille en or qui est revenu alors
elle est revenue quand même en deuxième
partie de soirée juste après koh lanta
c'est un choix c'est un choix curieux
les audiences ça a démarré un million
cent le 31 août et avec lui certains
c'est le mox est évident qu'en 2010 et
remis aux abbesses un petit peu le coup
on s'est posé la question est ce que tf1
était en train de tuer camille combal
petit récap on n'a pas pu tuer tout le
monde
[Applaudissements]
ça redémarre
sa
conjointe
jeu présenté par seulement calme tout
pensé au début mais je vais peut-être le
moins c'est
j bernard montiel moi j'ai présenté
cette émission moi c'était l'émission
que j'anime
aussi sur celui qui a été fait sur tf1
[Rires]
le concours là j'en ai fait pendant deux
ans moi j'adorais cette émission le
principe en revanche c'est pas une
émission du soir est clair
c'est de moderniser parce que le les
moderniser l ai bien fait d'ailleurs
c'est bien fait l'animation est un peu
kitsch et les candidats mais c'est
rigolo la mission extrêmement
sympathique où des familles s'opposent
avec des sondages je rappelle le
principe du jeu mais ses émissions
extrêmement sympathique mais qui n'a pas
sa place après 22 heures c'est
hallucinant c'est un truc 2010 alors est
ce que quelqu'un sait pourquoi s'étaient
placés en 2d partie de soirée où c'était
prévu comme ça dès le début parce qu'ils
mettent des fictions tous les jours que
ça cartonne et qu'ils ont plus la place
de m pendant la journée on en fin
d'après-midi urnes avec soirée mais
c'est encore un choix de programmation
qui est catastrophique c'est une
émission qui est pensé une émission
d'accueil pour les fins de journées
début de soirée et là ils la mettent à
23 heures ça n'a pas sa place ça c'est
comme s'ils mettaient danse avec les
stars 11 heures du matin sans aucun sens
gilles et je réponds oui à votre
question il
est ce que tf1 est en train de tuer
camille combal oui parce que trop de
formes à une surexposition sacré là
quand il fait télé depuis longtemps on a
émigré manière s'il avait
sifflé sur un format famille avec lui
ils ferment questionnement donc on sait
plus à quelle émission il s'identifie et
on est en train je trouve de le perdre à
force de le diluer dans plein
d'émissions cerner la question que je me
pose c'est pourquoi tu le fais venir
camille combal à tf1 tu le fais tu le
met en tête de gondole il et il a du
talent moi j'aime beaucoup ce mec là et
pourquoi tu lui mets une émission à
minuit à vous avez vu la voir si une
catastrophe labeouf si tu as une
chaussure pu apporter demain tu jettes
ma chaussure sa carrière
[Applaudissements]
si ta cabine s'est créé un programme la
famille en or li la di la présenter nuit
en 74 pas très cool
c'est patrick roy qui l'aiment énoncés
j'adorais est parti mais la famille en
or ces vieux ordonné le truc camille
combal et après on répondre à cette
question et boum ferait plaisir de
prendre pancartes à on n'est pas en
vacances le seuil n'est pas là qu'on
fait pas les petites pancartes un merci
beaucoup regarder la question la
question gymnase
[Musique]
rosello et 500 mille euros
moi aussi je veux bien voir si l'euro
quel est le cadeau qu'on va gagner notre
charmante voix off va nous dire ça et 10
à lui dit
et
alors là c'est les power rangers
seraient alors à toutes les couleurs
sens orange violet foncé
force verte enceintes chaque à distance
parce que c'est qu'ovide cacak pas papa
mais je crois que vous avez une passion
c'est vous cuisinez divinement bien
château c'est ça
son sort je vous le dis on ne va pas y
arriver
alors que oui avoue poursuit que tf1
entre un twin cam iron man 2 vient pour
le coup oui moi je trouve que camille il
est formidable et mériterait un
programme en même temps quand je regarde
les images comme ça ça me fait un peu
penser à burger quiz qui est aussi un
programme de soirée donc peut-être que
camille arrivera à faire en sorte que
cette mx cuse mois mercus à 21h c'est un
placebo mais ça
l'a fait c'est une heure
je pense que c'est un très bon animateur
mais je trouve que tf1 lui laisse trop
de place dans les émissions star qu'ils
l'ont fait venir en se disant voilà on
va casser un peu avec les animateurs
lice on va prendre un animateur drôle et
il est très drôle camille combal mais il
lui laisse énormément de place pour
faire des sketches pour faire du zèle
pour faire de l'humour etc alors que les
émissions de tf1 c'est sensé des
émissions très simple très mesquin et
qui met en avant les gens le programme
les autres là je trouve qu'on met
beaucoup en avant camille combal dans
les émissions là encore il fait des
sketches des parodies je ne sais pas si
sa place dans un jeu même si c'est très
drôle mais pour moi il le met trop en
avant et c'est ça qui peut à mon avis le
est ce qu'au départ c'est prévenir 18h
ou 19h il s'était tourné vers la fin du
défi chanter pour dépasser encore demain
après demain ça cartonne tous les toutes
les fictions carton qui vont laisser les
oisiens le fait pas non mais où ils
pensaient à l'époque c'était le les
balbutiements de 2 g récente annonce de
mission et non oui mais au départ ici
tout commence chez meys avait commencé
d'ailleurs j'ai donc commencé mais ça
m'intéresse terminaux scellés fermés
mais du coup comme ça marche très bien
il laisse la série ils ont raison et ça
ils savaient plus trop quoi faire donc
il le met en deuxième partie de soirée
n'est pas tellement mis en avant parce
que le mardi soir en deuxième partie de
soirée finalement il est un petit peu à
la cave donc ça va il fait ses armes je
pense sur ce truc là je pense
en
tout cas et je pense que c'est un format
dont il avait envie parce qu'il est bon
dans ce genre de chose justement une du
très bon il laisse de la place mendès
qui fait du sketch parce qu'ils rigolent
et déconne avec les familles maintenant
effectivement il n'est pas non plus
hyper exposé sur cette émission à cette
case là il devrait dire non parfois ils
devraient dire non
il a joué au centre exemple l'énergie
non mais à lui de dire non à lui de dire
je ne me fais pas ça et je trouve qu'il
a envie de trop de produire de faire
trop de choses je le comprends ils en
plaine il s'estime en pleine réussite de
gagner beaucoup d'argent mais il faut se
faire rares parfois là il est en train
de se perdre complètement quand on à tf1
d'avoir été il voyait les bernard c'est
assez compliqué il va lui dire non
je voulais aussi compliqué quant à vous
avez le le patron de cette cour d'appel
voilà on a une mission pour toi c'est un
jeu important que c'est compliqué de
dire non oui mais il fait presque tous
les jeux et ça ne correspond pas
tellement credo gagne un million moi ça
m'a gêné des millions
et des millions ce soit camille combal
par exemple sauf que c'est pas sa place
comme dans une famille en or je préfère
voir christophe dechavanne en revanche
jean camille l'image il est parfait
parce que c'est une émission qui lui
correspondait je pense que c'est pas son
domaine animateur de jeu mais ce qui est
plus compliqué non mondiale après celle
de
savatan jamin qui l'a fait aussi avec
brio merci ils sont pas tant que ça au
final j'étais pas avec brio
on
connaît pas la nature de son contrat
avec tf1 ce que quand il est parti à tf1
lui a dit ok mais par contre tu va
accepter en les conditions c'est sa
salopette alors je vous expliquais vous
avez un contrat de batterie le contrat
d'exclusivité vous avez une base à des
garanties après soit dans 7 dans cette
base là vous avez l'obligation de
travailler pour eux ces deux
possibilités soit c'est un accès
indépendant et vous avez votre contrat
du coup il dit et en plus les émissions
pouvait accepter ou refuser mais je
connais très peu d'animateurs car
faisait c'est très compliqué
comment et pas seulement sur tf1 moi je
me suis envolée des mines qui ont
proposé plein de trucs et chaque fois on
me disait si tu refuses à attention par
l'autre truc que tu veux tu l'auras pas
et il a été amené à accepter les choses
qu'il aurait bien voulu refuser oui je
me dire l'enquêté fans partout quand on
est en position relative faiblesse on
accepte même si camille est pas en
position de faiblesse c'est
effectivement difficile de refuser des
choses qu'il aime en plus la wii devient
par sa l'analyse de guillaume est très
bonne mais merci c'est qu'on est sûr que
ça vous plaise que des iris